hello and welcome to this video I am
bascom as my opponent I have this vague
feeling no okay I was thinking if we had
some exchange Ruiz before somehow but
I'm absolutely I wasn't I wasn't surgeon
in the first place and it seems some
yeah it's not the case okay so take 93
just developing here is correct g37 I
hit d5 for now no F the knight on c3
okay that doesn't make much sense then
so let's castle okay mm-hmm so once the
developers g6 and yeah that's that's
very sensible way of doing things let's
see is there something there's no real
tactical way of doing things like the we
got six square looks a little bit
suspicious but probably nothing much
going on down okay so that looks fairly
equal disposition probably I'm did not
play it in the most are testing way
I think trading this Bishop makes sense
I expect him to castle now okay it
probably leads to almost the same thing
so this is a ticket and okay 96 35 maybe
hmm where do i go on the key em so 95 is
indeed coming so after that we should be
three doesn't look good I can go a fall
down yeah I think I go at four just take
on shoulder 15 yeah let's do this I
don't want to spend it take a piece
covering the beep on a little bit lame
ok so now if 5 is a threat
yeah this is possible but I felt it
looks quite weakening so I'm going to
take a guess on if I've is also not bad
let's go with five and well it wasn't
quite sure him he cannot go d 5 because
of night a for that looks strategically
very dubious unless there's a tactic but
don't see it and I'm threatening now
probably to take like Ed 6cd 6 rupee 6
that is probably a threat rookie 696
Bishop c4 and his pinned on that c4 g8
diagonal it looks like a threat to me
yeah I thought night a force it's very
dubious and sorry I thought this is
dubious because of an idea for so let's
do it he's got c4 but I just moved the
bishop and then I don't really know
doesn't do it ok but Quincy three what
is coming now didn't see it move after
that c5 is just dropping that what's the
main thing d5 was weakening c5
enormously and winnings if I land before
fence Katie disconnection ok with this
person gradually which yeah as we often
stated disconnecting is a way to resign
as well yeah ok so we had a fairly
offbeat way the Steinitz yeah I believe
that this is kind of normal we can show
that or castles but it shouldn't make
much of a difference
the computer likes d5 but I don't what I
don't like is him that compared to the
Kings Indian my porn is blocked blocked
if I would have the pawn on c4 and I
would be happy but this isn't all that
clear to me engine goes right but I mean
one thing is this is clear like after
this Black has a slight issue here with
this King side so like nochi six runs
into H foyer that's also what the engine
gives ng6 maybe the same thing it's a
little bit annoying right okay castles
this cannot really be bad okay Bishop g5
and 95 is good I was yeah i was thinking
briefly about it but it looked a little
bit too fantastic to me to spend time on
it mmm yeah that's nice i can take this
lent him some stuff is probably winter
now the engine gives the win yeah this
is the way I already said f6 is weakish
but somehow I didn't follow up on that
so I played like normals this and I
think hear the engine gives a roughly
equal of minimum advantage for why this
is what I expected Chifa g5 was not on
my radar that's a cool ideas 96 and
control of 85 Wow
so not that's not an easy move to make
for a human player okay introduced by
the slight edge but so it's a very
unconventional solution here so here I
under think f4 makes sense gain space
the NT mp3 again ya know or I had the
director five as an idea at least what's
the engine gives 95 yeah maybe 95 this
makes some sense that c3 is an idea okay
with that that cannot possibly be bad go
back at five and now I'm sure Heather
the engine wants to take I kind of
suspected that that this is probably
better but I also likely five yeah here
home he has to take me this I saw this
position that I wasn't totally sure 9594
white wine somewhat better yeah this is
engine really dislikes but it got
justified immediately I mean one thing
that I saw is that let's say black
plates nothing nothing move camera it's
very stupid one but then then I have
this this this kind of tactic is on the
radar okay the engine defined defenses
but that's what I saw and this I think
is very problematic after after 94 I'm
just see for I actually intended to play
but should be toward Queen III looks
looks strong this however also should be
at ladder for Wyatt okay maybe this kind
of thing there to control so far it's
better for white but not decisive but
after you after this it gets very ugly
because I'm winning c-54 absolutely
nothing and this is not just them upon
but also the controller all the dark
squares pretty awful ok guys thanks for
watching